te voy a contar otro acertijo una vez
más yo no lo inventé de hecho la verdad
no me acuerdo dónde lo leí por primera
vez creo que fue detrás de una revista
no sé tal vez la científica american lo
que recuerdo es que andaba con unos
cuates de mochilazo por europa y
teníamos como pasatiempo para los viajes
largos resolver estos acertijos de atrás
de las revistas lo cual me recuerda que
tengo que decirte algo casi todas las
personas leen uno de estos piensan un
ratito del acertijo y si no le sale
piensan que son malos este es un ejemplo
de que no es así mis cuates y yo
estuvimos discutiendo lo por
literalmente un día y no nos salió luego
me fui a dormir y como si fuera magia en
la mañana corrí a decirles ella y lo
resolví así que como consejo te
recomiendo escuchar el problema luego
entenderlo y pues no se detiene el vídeo
piénsalo por 24 horas y luego regresa
esto tiene la ventaja de que o lo
resuelves lo cual está padre o no y si
no cuando veas la solución vas a
sentirte mucho más satisfecho
comencemos este es el problema de los
intercambian test de los intercambian
test y como en varios de estos problemas
tiene que ver con tipos de persona que
de alguna forma pues distorsionan la
verdad el problema dice lo siguiente
comenzamos con 5 chicos en frente de ti
1 2 3 4 5 chicos o chicas como prefieras
no hay razón especial para que sean ni
chicos y chicas
las situaciones que cuatro de ellos son
intercambian tes voy a apuntarlo cuatro
de ellos son intercambian test y lo que
hace un intercambian t es responder de
forma curiosa a las preguntas tú le vas
a hacer preguntas en la primera pregunta
va a decir la verdad o va a mentir lo
que quiera pero tú no sabes que entonces
ese es en la primera pregunta pero en la
segunda va a intercambiar entonces por
ejemplo si en la primera pregunta te
dijo la verdad ahora en la segunda
pregunta te va a mentir entonces
intercambia de verdad a mentira pero si
mintió la primera vez entonces ahora te
va a decir la verdad luego en la tercera
pregunta va a seguir de este modo o sea
si empezó diciendo la verdad y luego
mintió ahora en la tercera pregunta va a
decir la verdad entonces déjame darte un
ejemplo por ejemplo si yo fuera un
intercambio ante y me preguntas por mi
nombre entonces la primera vez yo puedo
decirte pues no sé me llamo un memo
entonces pues claramente te estoy
mintiendo pero la segunda vez que me
preguntes cuál es mi nombre te voy a
decir y me llamo sal
pero luego si me preguntas una vez más
te voy a decir mi nombre es lourdes y la
cuarta vez te voy a decir mi nombre es
sal entonces esto de aquí quiere decir
que la primera vez decidí mentir pero
igual de fácil pude haber decidido que
en la primer pregunta yo quería decir la
verdad o sea en el primer cómo te llamas
pude haber respondido mi nombre es sal y
entonces la segunda vez que me preguntas
pude haber dicho pues no sé mi nombre es
alfredo y luego la tercera vez que me
preguntaste diría es sal y finalmente no
sé te diría cualquier nombre lo que sea
que no sea sal digámosle o cualquier
cosa arbitraria pero bueno creo que más
o menos ves la idea verdad un
intercambian te supongamos el la primera
vez que le preguntes puede decidir si
decir la verdad o si mentir pero si
miente la primera vez entonces la
siguiente vez va a decir la verdad
ahora también puede pasar lo contrario
la primera vez puede decirte la verdad y
entonces a la siguiente pregunta lo que
va a hacer es cambiar es decir va a
mentirte eso de ahí es un intercambian
te ahora seguro desde aquí ya pues te
está dando un poquito de dolor de cabeza
como a mí me pasó porque es como que
mucho más fácil cuando en cierto
problema las personas siempre mienten o
siempre dicen la verdad aquí no sólo
intercambian sino que además no sabemos
con qué empiezan pueden empezar diciendo
la verdad o pueden empezar mintiendo o
sea no hay ninguna una forma en la cual
podemos saber que esta persona digamos
es un intercambian te pero además aunque
lo supiéramos no sabemos si va a empezar
diciendo la verdad o si va a empezar
mintiendo vale ya quedamos en que cuatro
son intercambian test y el quinto bueno
a lo mejor y adivinaste es muy
predecible el quinto va a ser una
persona veraz
él o ella no sé no nos importa otra vez
el género pero bueno es una persona
verás que siempre dice la verdad
que siempre dice la verdad entonces de
lo que se trata este acertijo o bueno la
meta de este acertijo es determinar cuál
de estas cinco personas es la persona
veraz es decir me voy a poner por aquí
la meta es quién es la persona veraz y
como suele suceder en este tipo de
acertijos no tienes una infinidad de
preguntas de hecho sólo tienes dos
preguntas para determinar esto entonces
tienes dos preguntas
muy bien ahora estas dos preguntas
puedes hacerlas a él y a él digamos o
bien puedes hacerle ambas preguntas a
ella o ambas a él es decir tienes dos
preguntas y no tienen que ser a la misma
persona podrían ser a la misma persona
verdad bueno puedes hacer combinaciones
de personas o como quieras la cosa es
que tienes dos preguntas para
preguntarle a cualquier combinación de
personas y esas personas pueden
repetirse vale va otra vez el reto del
acertijo tienes que hacer dos preguntas
a cualquier combinación de personas y
con eso determinar con toda seguridad
quién es la persona verás bueno este es
el acertijo ahorita es un muy buen
momento para detener el vídeo para
pensarlo para pues ya sabes ir a comer
cenar dormir y todo y después de esto
regresa regresa ve la solución o ve
algunas sugerencias y con esto vas a
disfrutar mucho más del problema estos
problemas que tardas en resolver son los
que se disfrutan más en lógica y en
matemáticas vale entonces bueno ve
descansa
ahora vamos a empezar con la respuesta a
partir de este momento ojala ahorita ya
hayas regresado no haya dormido hayas
pensado mucho y hayas disfrutado mucho
pensarlo y entonces ahora si vamos a
empezar espero que estés listo para ver
la solución o mejor aún para confirmarla
vamos a empezar con una sugerencia
o sea cómo le podemos hacer para
determinar que alguna persona está
mintiendo o si ese ínter cambiante o si
es veraz o algo así o sea realmente como
que no hay nada de información al inicio
entonces una buena observación es que al
inicio como no sabes nada de nadie no
importa a quién le preguntes la primera
cosa que le quieres preguntar es decir
en la solución la primer pregunta no
tiene por qué depender de ninguna
persona entonces como que la primera
pregunta lo que nos tiene que dar es un
cierto todo tipo de información que nos
dé una pista de qué va a pasar en la
segunda pregunta entonces eso es algo
clave queremos hacer una primer pregunta
para que en la segunda pregunta sepamos
cómo va a actuar la persona ésta es la
sugerencia por si quieres detener
ahorita el vídeo
pero ahora sí pasemos a la pregunta 1
ahora puedes preguntarse la quien quiera
ser otra vez como el problema es
simétrico no hay ninguna razón para
pensar que alguien pues es más veraz que
los demás entonces pregunta número 1
vamos a preguntar tú eres la persona
veraz
a persona verás va entonces vamos a
pensar en los escenarios que van a
ocurrir tras hacer esta pregunta lo
primero que va a pasar es que nos va a
decir que sí por qué no entonces va a
decir que sí o bien va a decir que no
analicemos qué sucede en estos casos si
la persona dice que sí cuando le
preguntamos si es la persona verás
quiere decir que en efecto es la persona
verás verdad sería la persona verás
diciendo la verdad diciendo la verdad o
bien que es un intercambian te que está
diciendo una mentira entonces es un
intercambian te que está mintiendo ahora
si la persona dice que no es la persona
verás entonces claramente no es la
persona verás porque la persona veraz no
puede mentir acerca de ser la persona
veraz entonces la única opción es que
esa persona es intercambian te y que nos
está diciendo la verdad desde ese
momento entonces si dice que no va a ser
un intercambian t
que dice la verdad recuerda o sea le
estoy preguntando a cualquiera de estas
cinco personas si es la persona verás si
dice que sí entonces inmediatamente sé
qué o bien es la persona verás diciendo
la verdad o bien es un intercambian te
que está mintiendo si dice que no sé que
tiene que ser un intercambian te que
está diciendo la verdad ahora lo que
está interesante es que si dice que sí
podemos saber muy bien cómo va a
reaccionar frente a la segunda pregunta
porque pues si es una persona veraz
también nos va a responder con la verdad
en la segunda pregunta entonces va a
decir la verdad
para decir la verdad en la pregunta
número dos muy bien pero si es un
intercambio ante que está mintiendo qué
es lo que va a ser pues como es un
intercambian te y acaba de mentir
entonces la segunda vez va a decir la
verdad entonces también va a decir la
verdad en la pregunta número 2
esto está súper padre porque qué sucede
si la persona dice que sí cuando le
preguntamos si es la persona veraz
entonces inmediatamente sabemos que nos
va a decir la verdad en la segunda
ocasión entonces pues ya sabiendo que
siempre va a decir la verdad en la
segunda pregunta pues le preguntamos
obviamente quien es la persona verás
es la persona verás muy bien entonces
está un poquito raro verdad le preguntas
primero a alguien si es la persona verás
y si dice que si le preguntas quién es
la persona verás y claro o bien va a ser
la persona verás que va a decir pues
obvio soy yo o bien va a ser un
intercambian te que va a decir a ese
tipo de por allá by con esto vamos a
poder determinar quién es la persona
verás pero qué pasa si dice que no o sea
si empieza siendo un intercambian te que
dice la verdad pues la segunda vez va a
mentir entonces va a mentir en la
pregunta número dos va en la pregunta
número dos ok entonces ahora lo que
tenemos que hacer es formular una
pregunta inteligentemente de alguna
forma para que siempre que nos mienta
podamos determinar quién es la persona
veraz entonces si nos dice que no la
segunda vez vamos a hacer esta pregunta
quien no es la persona veraz
y fíjate esta pregunta está muy bien
planeada porque la única forma en la
cual se puede mentir a esta pregunta es
responder quien si es la persona veraz
va entonces pues simplemente ya no le
queda escapatoria más que decirte de
adeveras quién es la persona verás
entonces dependiendo del caso o sea si
nos dicen que sí pues podemos predecir
que nos va a decir la segunda vez una
verdad y si nos dice que no podemos
predecir que en la siguiente ocasión nos
va a mentir en cualquier caso podemos
formular una segunda pregunta que nos
permita saber lo que queremos
bueno como puedes ver el juego del
mentiroso que hicimos en el vídeo pasado
nos sirvió de calentamiento para este
espero que te haya gustado y nos vemos
en el siguiente vídeo